en el último vídeo empezamos a explorar
lo que es el teorema de stocks y lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es ver si es
consistente con algunas de las ideas que
ya hemos visto por ejemplo si de esta
forma podemos hacerlo consistente con
algunos otros teoremas entonces voy a
empezar a hacer como casi siempre
algunos dibujos voy a pintar los ejes
digamos ok entonces vamos a hacer este
otro eje
finalmente este otro que va a ser caps
el eje
de las 10 aquí está el eje de las 10
es el eje de las equis
ok y este vertical por supuesto es el
eje de las setas y ahora vamos a
imaginar una una región que esté
contenida únicamente en el plano xy por
ejemplo algo que se vea como de esta
forma no sé y esta región sólo para
hacer buena onda con ella vamos a
ponerle un nombre y que se llame r ok
entonces tengo esta región que solo está
contenido en el plano xy y que además de
todo pues está definida por una curva
cerrada si queremos utilizar el teorema
de stocks como lo vimos en el vídeo
pasado voy a tener que definir esta
curva pero además como la recorro y como
ya es costumbre voy a recorrerla como en
el sentido contrario a las manecillas
del reloj de esta forma le pongo las
flechitas para que sea más claro
entonces recorremos esta curva en ese
sentido entonces que es lo único que nos
falta para poder usar el teorema de
stocks pues es un campo vectorial y me
voy a tomar uno muy particular digamos
qué efe s/a pd xy que es una función que
sólo depende de x y en la primera
componente en la dirección x más una
función q que también sólo depende de xy
de y en la dirección del vector j y no
vamos a tener ninguna componente en la
dirección z entonces aquí puedo tener yo
distintas cosas no sé a lo mejor cosas
muy locas pero el detalle es que una vez
que yo tengo esto como no tengo ninguna
condición sobre la la la componente z
entonces todo esto queda contenido en el
plano xy además si yo me elevo por
ejemplo por acá arriba voy a tener que
todos estos vectores son los mismos pues
sólo dependen de xy de ye verdad
entonces déjenme déjenme bueno va a
dejarlo así sale entonces lo que ahora
sí voy a poder hacer es calcular la
integral de esta sobre esta curva del
campo vectorial
efe pero estamos integrando a lo largo
de nuestra curva
y multiplicamos por de er a lo largo de
esta curva verdad donde la curva es la
frontera muy bien entonces si quiere
usar el teorema de stocks esto me dice
que va a ser la integral doble sobre la
superficie pero la superficie en
realidad es sólo nuestra región r
ok lo único que nos falta determinar es
quién es el rotacional de este campo
vectorial y quién es el vector normal
unitario pero bueno al menos podemos
decir que lo que sea que eso sea va a
multiplicar a una diferencial de área no
donde ya sabemos que que significa eso
entonces vamos a ver quién es el
rotacional de f
vamos a ver el rotacional de f podemos
calcularlo como el un determinante
verdad al menos nemo técnicamente esto
es el determinante de los vectores y
jota y acá en nuestra primera fila luego
en la segunda ponemos la parcial
respecto de x la parcial respecto de ye
y la parcial respecto de z y aquí
ponemos las entradas de nuestro campo
vectorial que son
en la dirección x q en la dirección y 0
en la dirección zeta
entonces al calcular este determinante
este determinante vamos a hacerlo va a
ser nos tomamos primero y que multiplica
a este sub determinante la parcial de 0
respecto de cero menos la parcial de cv
respecto ez pero que sólo depende de xy
de y no de z así que esto es 0 ahora
menos nos tomamos la segunda que es jota
que multiplica a la parcial de cero
respecto de x que es cero menos la
parcial de p respecto de z pero otra vez
que sólo depende de x y así que esto es
cero
ahora nos tomamos el vector k que
multiplica a este sub determinante la
parcial de q respecto de x parcial de q
respecto de x menos la parcial de p
respecto de y ok entonces notemos que
esto se hace cero verdad porque 0 -0 es
cero y solo nos queda que el rotacional
es esto lo único que nos falta
determinar es ver quién es nuestro
vector normal unitario y regresemos al
dibujo veamos que esta superficie en
realidad es una porción de plano
entonces un vector normal es el que
apunta en la dirección vertical así esto
ya es ortogonal es perpendicular a esa
región de plano por lo tanto para que
tenga vector normal el perdón para que
tenga norma 1 unitaria entonces nuestro
vector n no es otra cosa más que el
vector cada verdad justo el vector acá
es el vector que apunta en la dirección
vertical y que tiene norma 1 así que n
es acá qué es lo que nos queda entonces
al sustituir en la fórmula del teorema
de stocks pues tenemos la parcial el
rotacional que es parcial de q respecto
de x menos la parcial de p respecto de
iu y luego multiplicamos cada punto acá
pero que apuntó que es simplemente la
norma de acá y la norma de acá es 1 así
que esto es lo único que nos queda por
calcular y si eres bastante
si tienes muy buena memoria recordarás
que esto no es otra cosa más que el
famosísimo teorema de greene el teorema
de greene
entonces qué es lo que estamos
concluyendo el teorema de green es un
caso especial del teorema de stocks para
cuando tengo un campo vectorial definido
de esta forma y la regional a lo largo
de la cual estoy integrando es
simplemente con esta contenida en un
plano por una curva cerrada ok entonces
no hemos demostrado aún el teorema de
stocks no lo hemos aún demostrado sin
embargo ya vemos que al menos tiene
bastante
o al menos coincide muy bien con lo que
ya hemos visto hasta ahora que es el
teorema de greene verdad al menos esto
le da sentido y todo esto lo hicimos
basado en la intuición del último vídeo